greetings from podcastville it's
wednesday the 6th of january
the joint is brought to you by on it
listen
on it does not [__] around alpha brain
shroom tech
new mood alpha brain powder that you put
in water shake it up
and drink it for memory focus
sharpness just everything you're looking
for alpha brain
is so [__] good that if you don't
like it it doesn't work for you
for some reason hey listen i got a
friend he takes an edible nothing
happens
i've tried to [__] and i've given him
800 milligrams
and he sits there and spits at my face
sometimes things affect people in
different ways
i know alpha brain works for me every
time i'm on a [__] cycle i'm like
[__]
speeding gonzales i'm ready to rock
alpha brain if you don't like it though
send your money back and you can keep
the [__] product
that's a company right there that's a
company that stands behind that product
go to audit.com right now take a look at
the selection they got
they got protein bites that'll knock
your [__] pants off
they got melatonin in their spray
they're saying it helps with colvin
they've got protein powders alpha brain
shroom tech
alpha brain instinct you can't [__]
lose
press in church and get ten percent off
your first order
c h u r c h church
joey whatever the [__] and get 10 off
delivered right to your [__] house
i'm without it you understand me
and the joint is also brought to you by
oh [__]
draftkings it's [__] january cocktail
you know what that means [__]
guinness you got college basketball you
got the playoffs
you got pro basketball i think hockey's
around the [__] corner somewhere
but let's not worry about nothing let's
worry about what's in front of us
you got the [__] playoffs
tonight you got nba
get ready because the playoffs start
this [__] weekend all right
there's no better place to get in on the
action better than draftkings
america's top rated sportsbook if you
haven't tried them yet
what the [__] are you waiting for to
celebrate
this time of the year draftkings is
giving you a shot you ready for this
to double your money this saturday all
it takes is one touchdown
and you can double your money i'm gonna
paint a picture for you right this is
you on saturday
you smoke a number you place a bet you
have mama lick your nuts
and put your feet up and go to bed as
soon as somebody hits the first
touchdown
you're getting paid [__] you understand
me so download the top rated draftking
sportsbook app
today right now as we speak use promo
code joey when you sign up
and have a shot at doubling your money
doubling if a touchdown is scored
this saturday what are you doing this
saturday what are you doing right now
dick you're going to be on a [__]
computer let's make a little [__] g
this year all right
this saturday that doubling your money
if the touchdown is scored that's code
joey for new players to get a shot
at dublin you get us this [__]
saturday
for limited time only at draftkings
sportsbook listen
the party's on saturday but the party
really starts tonight there's
some great nba on the board tonight take
a look go to draftkings right now
download the app right now
as we speak pushing joey and
[__] saturday you're going to double
your [__] money as soon as the first
touchdown is [__]
scored and here's the part the lawyers
make me say you got to be 21 older
new jersey indiana pennsylvania only see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details you got a gaming
problem
there's help call 1-800 gambler or if
you're in indiana call 1-800
with it but if you don't have a gaming
problem oh [__]
light your balls on fire it's time to
make some [__] guitars
download draftkings code joey
candles lick [__] suckers
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's up you bad [__] it's
wednesday
the sixth it's a beautiful [__] day
to be alive
it's surgery week i'm walking around
having a nervous breakdown you know what
i'm saying
listen the good thing about this [__]
surgery is
i'm gonna have a [__] tremendous
story for you guys i already got stories
from the weak
distress test i'm saving them i'm
holding on to them because today's a
special date
but uh [__] friday i can't but i've
been having anxiety attacks
the other day at the gym on monday i
[__] started lifting
and i couldn't catch my breath at one
point and i started sweating
profusiously on a lot of joey deers
i don't know if anybody ever saw me
before i got clean off coke
after i got clean off coke on stage i
wouldn't sweat
when i was doing coke and i would go on
stage
oh my [__] god what would come out of
me it was like a steam bat
i would sweat [__] profusiously can
you believe that what a difference
like have you ever seen me you've never
really seen me sweaty
on stage you don't you don't see me i
don't sweat at all at all
not even my [__] armpits they're
drier than [__]
but when i was snorting coke and i would
go on stage
an onslaught of sweat would just [__]
come out of it let me tell you something
every time the funniest thing about
surgery for me is i always got to give
blood
or you always got to [__] you know
that to [__] give you like a
what do you call it intravenous whatever
that [__] is i got to tell you something
whenever the nurses grab my hand they
always go hmm
you're a big palmy no [__] i'm about to
you're about to
i'm about to do what i hate doing the
most anything to do medically
i listen i don't give a [__] you know me
i'm [__] out of my mind
thank god i thank god
every [__] day that i don't like
needles because
i wouldn't be here right now i'd be a
[__] needle i would have became a
heroin [__] junkie
thank god i don't have that [__] that
you know some people could look at
needles and
i just saw a shot on [__] 60 minutes
last night
and i almost fainted sitting there two
nights ago three nights ago i'm watching
60 minutes
and the [__] and they gave somebody like
a vaccine shot and i had to look away i
almost [__] fainted my wife looked at
him and she goes oh that one got you
you know like sometimes you get stuck
looking at the tv you don't turn away
soon enough
that's what happened i was all moment up
and [__] all of a sudden i'm like
what the
what the [__] like i can't stand this
[__]
but so this week i'm gonna have some
type of story for you hopefully monday
i'll be cause i know i have to do
physical therapy monday and i gotta
[__] drive no no i don't have to
drive
somebody's gonna have to [__] drive
me i'm not i got like 10 drivers on
[__] car right now
so but i start physical therapy on
monday so i really don't know
what my schedule is i'm gonna talk to
mike and we're gonna try to make this
[__] happen
even if i have to do it from a couch or
from my [__] recliner
whatever the [__] we need we're gonna
bring you something you know i'm sorry
if i'm not gonna look good uh
what are you gonna do look what do i do
do you think like i'm
i'm not even i don't give a [__] anymore
i'm past
the point of wanting to look good i'm
just one i just want to live
and not get covered that's it can you
imagine i get covered i don't
think [__] surgery that's another
thing i'm living with all week
what if i get cold but my friend wanted
to come over i told no
my other buddy wanted to go to dinner
i'm avoiding him like he's [__] got
aids
you know i'm just avoiding everybody
like i just want
i want to do this surgery i'm not going
to check it out on you guys you know you
know me better than that
i went uh the other day i saw jim
florentine the brother bob
great guy all his brother's a great guy
but bob is just
extra sweet and bob is like listen man
if you need to write down there on
friday i'll give you a ride like what if
it's at six in the morning he goes you
got it i'll give you a ride
and i'm looking at him i'm like this guy
doesn't know that if it gives me a ride
i just might hug him to death like i
might just hold him in the car and say
don't let me don't let them take me
don't let him take me because
you know he's such a sweetheart so i
don't know
i'm hoping that i'm only [__] with
you guys you guys know that
i'll [__] walk in there i'll swallow
my little [__] [__]
attitude and i'll get this done with i'm
just
this is not my foot this is not one of
my strong points
when i did my strengths and weaknesses
number one was going to doctors
it's not my strong point dog i swear to
god you don't want to make an
appointment for the doctor
and they make it like let's say i'm
going to see a doctor i need it could be
anything
because you you can't trust nobody they
always you always i always ask them i
don't care if i have to go to the doctor
for my toe i'm like
is there going to be a needle involved
and they're like they shouldn't be
okay i just want to know because every
once in a while they'll throw
by the way on me i'll get down and
they're like oh wait we have to do a
blood test or something
i'm like i'm not [__] prepared i need
my [__] little earphones
i need my little [__] santana and my
ipod oh
there's a process for me to give blood
like before the stress that's the other
day
you're not even gonna know what the [__]
i did and how [__] you uncle joey
really is
see i'm [__] and i've told you
people for
years but you people don't believe me
you think i'm [__] with you
i'm [__] so i have a stress test at
9 15.
i couldn't eat three hours before the
stress test so i set the alarm for four
i got up and i ate i smoked dope and i
ate even though
i wasn't supposed to smoke dope for the
24 hours before the [__] thing i
couldn't drink caffeine you know
i got to go there without [__] coffee
you know how hard it is
to get in your car to go you do you have
any idea how hard it is for a guy like
me
to get in this car and drive
to go get a needle do you have any
[__] idea it's like driving to go
follow don my reverend back in the day
like when i see my name on the schedule
in the main room and i go
who am i following like dominion [__]
i have to drive down sunset doing like
20.
like [__] 20 in the right hand lane
if there was a guy
like you know a car popped up i would
pray to god thank god there's a valet
[__] stuck holding up to this line
i don't want to go to the store and
[__] die a slope that
it's worse than that when i have to go
to the [__] doctor like i have to go
all the way to [__]
i don't even know i don't want to say
where i got to go
it's like 20 minutes 20 20 20 25 minute
drive
those 25 minutes guys the air will be
down
to 60 in my car i will be pouring sweat
will be coming out of me
my handlebars if i'm going to make a
right you'll see my hands slip off the
steering wheel
because my hands become just [__]
they just become like a sponge man
so i'm looking forward to this the lat
i'm doing the same thing i did when i
got the fat ball taken out
i'm gonna the night before i'm gonna go
to the bank and take out 200 bucks and
50s
and shove them up my ass during the
surgery so if i have to make a quick
getaway after the surgery i got no
problems
the time when they took the fat ball out
of my neck though i put 450
bills up my ass i cupped them up real
small
and i kept them in there because they
don't let you put underwear on i told
you i'm [__] did i not tell you i'm
[__]
i put i took the 50 i folded them i fold
them again
i fold them again and i didn't put it
all the way up my [__] i'm not a
[__]
system yeah just but deep deep deep like
during the surgery
like the tip of the 50 dollar bill was
taking particular my [__] or whatever
when i woke up in [__] recovery
i went off that's what i'm scared of the
most that my wife has to go
pick me up because she can't you know he
can't go to the hospital and be there
so my wife is gonna have to go pick me
up so they're gonna have to call my wife
and i'm gonna have to wait those 20 30
minutes
let me tell you something those 20 30
minutes of me waiting
are gonna be [__] in a recovery room
you have no [__] idea and you're
hungry and you're thirsting you're gonna
have a mask on
you have no [__] idea how petrified i
am right now
but or how petrified i was that day when
they took the fat ball out
when i woke up and i've had
one two three
four four surgeries since i met you guys
yeah oh yeah i got put on the yeah i
don't
no no i did that once no no no no no no
listen guys when i go to the dentist
i only went under one time i don't like
that
dental pain is not that bad you could
you don't even feel a dentist i go to
dentists that i don't even [__] feel
when i did my teeth this last time that
[__] would dr sherry up in north
hollywood
i'd give her the highest recommendation
i didn't feel [__]
and you know me i'm a [__] [__] i
didn't feel
dick i even asked her to put more in
because i didn't feel nothing i want to
[__] it's like a fake little gokai
you're all [__] oh i remember driving
home i
somebody called me like what are you
doing i want here what's the matter joey
that's
that's the night yeah i'm over here
so a friend of mine accused me that
night she calls me up and she's like
you're slurring
yeah i'm [__] slurring because i've
been in a [__] dentist's chair
since that's listen this is anyway
i was in a dentist's chair from nine to
12.
and then they gave me a break and
i came back from 3 30
to 7 15.
do you want to [__] stand me they had
to do eight
[__] teeth and take them out and rip
them you have no [__] idea guys
i sat in that [__] thing they think
of your head getting drilled
from 3 30 to 7 30. and i kept telling
her throughout the thing popped me
hit it hit it hit it and she kept
popping me with these little things
picking it up and [__] big bang bang hit
it hit it
you know because i just didn't want to
feel the drill i could i could smell it
you could smell the [__]
the teeth in the air you're like what
the [__] whose [__] did i eat and
they got antiqued in my [__] teeth
the smell was [__] horrible but my
point is that when i walked out of there
i'll never forget this like you know i'm
gonna dent this chair for five [__]
hours four
let's not exaggerate joey four five
six yeah three hours three and a half
hours let's say
right getting hit with that [__] that
that liquid cocaine bang
bang bang bang i drive myself to cvs
while i'm at the dentist i'm missing
calls right i'm missing [__] calls
right so
my friend calls me she's like miss
[__] sober a.a
whatever but
uh you know she's concerned about me all
the time
so she called i called her back to go
how are you doing what's going on you
know
and she's telling me that also she goes
why are you slurring
and i go because i've been at the
[__] dentist since 3 30.
she's like you have a problem i'm like
what the [__] are you talking about like
i had to call her the next thing go what
the [__] is your problem
you [__] aa people like and i'm sorry
i don't mean to
there's some aaa people that take it to
an extreme i've supported her since day
one
and you know she lives in [__] uh
florida now whatever the [__] i've
supported her
since day one with her journey rehabs
the whole [__] thing
but when she this this final latch a.a
she's just been a nut she's been sober
now
ah maybe four years but she the only way
she could do it for her
was to be like you know like she's uh
she's the vp
and the treasurer of the n a and
she's like a regional whatever she had
to do this guys i've known her for 30
years she was a [__] mess
she had to do this so but we care about
each other you know
we've been friends since [__] boulder
we've been friends so when she
called me she's like hey man you know
what is your problem why are you high
because she always cease to watch the
podcast and go you're getting too high
on the podcast what the
we're just doing [__] animals i could
see if we were [__] doing
heroin and drinking booze and [__] i was
dying to drink new year's eve i didn't
have a [__] drink new year's eve
because i'm concerned about the [__]
sugar towards the diabetes can you
believe the fact i [__] become
20 years ago i would drink whatever the
[__] i wanted now
the other night when i made that video
for you guys the one without the volume
that i was and it got lost it's not on
youtube no more either
really yeah i can't find it i went to
find it because i was gonna dump it like
a chinese movie
i was gonna try to talk over it [__]
[__] with you guys
like rubble's gonna have mike redo it up
so i could
so i could talk during it over it and
[__] you know
like a chinese movie but i couldn't even
find it private so it's probably on
there you just can't see it yeah you
just can't [__] see it so
we'll do that i'm sorry about that guys
so yeah i'm at the [__] cbs
and she's like you're slurring yeah i'm
[__] slurring i've been i've been
[__] coked up for the last four
[__] hours but
you're going to pick up percocets or
something what medication yeah after
you leave the dentist they give you well
they gave me antibiotics
they gave me antibiotics they gave me
ibuprofen the strongest 1200 milligram
which are great compared to those
[__] you know that's
i'm i'm waiting for a call now from a
lady
that hangs out her daughter hangs out
with mercy
and she's a pharmacist at cvs he's the
head pharmacist that one of the cbs is
close to here
and i want to talk to her about my pain
options
so when i have the surgery i don't want
those oxy [__] codons
i don't want none of that [__] but i was
talking to kate quigley and she was
telling me that her boyfriend had the
knee surgery
and he went against the pain pills and
one night he woke up in the middle of
night
with [__] pain he had re knee
reconstruction
and he woke up [__] screaming and
pain and they had to take him back to
the hospital and
shoot him with a pain thing so i i i
don't know what to [__] do last time
i ate a [__] pain pill
was after that [__] dentist and
that's the day i fell off my [__]
bike
and that's that's it that's why i don't
have a f i don't want to take those
[__] pills
i fell off my [__] bike didn't even
know i was taking them i thought i was
taking the ibuprofen
and i left the [__] vikings right
next to it and i don't see without my
glasses so i just went in there
at four in the morning and popped one
i'm on the bike at seven
so i just had a bad experience with them
so i don't want nothing to do with them
it's january 6th
and about a week ago somebody sent me an
email it was
it's so weird how the karmic let's call
them the cop
the karma god works whatever god is out
there
i i don't know whatever energy is out
i don't know how it works but it's so
weird
uh january 6 is a birthday i'm somebody
who was very very close to me
and i let that person down
and every january [__] sixth
every year in january the first week of
january
i got a little bummed out uh it's weird
because my daughter's birthday's
friday so
you know i always think about january
6th
because uh it's a friend of mine's
birthday
that's what i was trying to say and
i let her down a long time ago
and i wanted to talk about it today to
keep her spirit alive you know
uh till this day i've always told people
that one of the guys most responsible
for helping my career i mean
like i've always said and i said you
need three people and you can take over
the [__] world
you know joe rogan has always been my
number one spokesman
he's always had my back in comedy you
know i got a bunch of those guys you
know
uh duncan harvey we're
all tight we were all woven from the red
band we're all woven from the same
uh ari really helped me out a lot with
comedy i we helped each other
um ari got me my agent but ari did
something he got me on that
this is not happening and
you know i've been friends with ari for
a long time so
i told ari a lot of stories of my life
and when he created this is not
happening
he would tell me what stories he wanted
to hear
on the stage you know
and uh except for the first time the
first time we did it
you know you got to give ari a lot of
credit you know what happened
with him was a year ago um he made a
mistake
it didn't change my opinion of him he's
just
a [__] knucklehead if you know ari
you know he's a knucklehead
and you know his intentions weren't bad
if you're still mad at them
go [__] yourself get over yourself you
know elvis is dead and i don't feel so
good myself
but ari is a great guy and he did
something
for me you know everybody has done
something different for me but
he looked at me from a different
direction he had heard me on the road
with rogan
you know me and him would stay
downstairs meet him a red man
and we would tell stories whatever and
he would hear these stories and i think
he would put like
mental notes in his mind i think he
[__] knew he wanted to do this
first time we did the storyteller show
he did that [__] thing
in the back of the improv no booze
it was ten bucks or five bucks to get in
there was maybe 50 people on the back it
was the back thing of the improv
and i remember going down there i was
gonna tell a story about
mugging somebody or something in hudson
county park
and i ended up when i was down there it
was mark maron
steve agee steve agee nice kid
and mark maron and i had to follow steve
and steve made a pink floyd reference
from mark maron
made a pink floyd reference so i went up
there and told the pink floyd story
and it was great i think it's still on
youtube you could tell that it was
the first this is not happening with no
[__] it was like a phone camera or
something
i think it's even in two parts you have
to look for uh
joey diaz pink floyd's story part one
and two i i think that's what it is you
know
i didn't have any idea what storytelling
was
i didn't know he just told me to come
down and tell a [__] story
i went on stage and told the story next
you know people were [__] crazy over
a [__] story
over a pink floyd story and then he kept
raising the levels
higher and higher you know then they
went on to digital
so before comedy central picked up the
show they went digital
and he came to me and he told me that he
wanted me to tell a story about the lady
who raised me and i was like my
godmother
and he goes no no the lady who took care
of you after your mother died and i'm
like
oh that's right it's so [__] weird
that
if you haven't seen that on this is not
happening
i think it's my best work and you know i
hate everything i [__] do i hate
everything i do
i hate the dog i hate everything i do
but this is not happenings to me
on my best [__] work because i was
free
it was ferrari like my motivation was
different
it was ferrari it really wasn't for the
audience it was for ari i
wanted to i didn't want ari to
look bad i'm one of those dudes and when
it comes to my friends
i don't want you to look bad i think
people always say why do you pay for the
ufc's
you could just steal them i'll give you
the code and i'm like
what would happen if [__] dana white
knew i stole a thing
and called joe how embarrassed would i
be joe would say to me all you need to
do is call me i'll give you the seventy
[__] dollars you know what i'm saying
i mean so when it came to ari and comedy
central
i had to give him the best because out
of respect for him
did you ever see me in comedy central
doing anything else no
ari went to comedy central and said you
got to put homie on
and even though they were like no he's
not you know he's not one of our little
[__] gentiles that
is safe arie said you got to put him up
this guy's going to take it to a next
[__] level
and if you watch those things i [__]
did because i knew ari had to fight for
me to get me on those things
but one of the best ones i ever did with
the one
with beating up the nun is good you know
he loved that one i remember the first
time i told him that
he [__] went crazy and he told me say
it on stage
and then we came to new york and [__]
he made
him before we went up i go i don't know
what i'm going to do tonight an hour he
goes
just tell a story tell this thing goes i
dare you to tell that [__] story
about
uh you know [__] uh beating up the
nun that's how that came out
guys i did that cold
opening up for new york and for rogan at
a theater in new york maybe
10 years ago
cold never wrote it on paper never did
nothing
he goes go up there and just try it but
he got to lose like oh you're right i
got nothing to lose
i [__] went up there and destroyed
the first time
with that nun joke just from [__]
memory
then i went home and sat down and
polished it up and added the [__] you
know
the puerto ricans and i love italian and
we picked her up by the feet
we took her shoes that came later but
the original
bro this is crazy
every every time i go to carny like i
had to go to connie a couple weeks ago
i go over to that [__] school and i
look at that school it's like a [__]
playground now whatever the [__] it is
i can't believe we beat up that [__]
nut until this day i really cannot
[__] believe that and i'm gonna go to
hell for that but
ari i already went like i already wanted
that story like i think i
the the first thing i did with arie was
is all right he really wanted me to tell
the zoraida story because people got to
know about this because
people think your mother just died and
you were an orphan
you know people i want people that you
were taken care of and i never said that
i was just
you know i never wanted people to think
that my mother just died and i ended up
on the [__] street that wasn't the
case at all
the vendors took me and i had options
okay
it wasn't like i and it was so weird
like nobody contacted me
like you said your mother dies the state
contacts you and says
who you living with you're gonna have to
go to a group home
until they adopt you or whatever nobody
said nothing to me it was like nothing
ever happened
i just got up and moved in with the
vendors we didn't register we didn't do
anything
but the only two living relatives i
basically had
was my sister in cuba she was no good to
me and my uncles and aunts in cuba
and i had an uncle in california and he
was me and him were on the [__] outs
so the only one at that time we went on
the arts we were
i was young when my mother died he came
to the funeral he
you know he did his brotherly thing and
he left after a couple days he gave me
some money
and he gave me his number and he said
call me if he needs something he need to
come out
and i took it up i took the offer up
four years later that's a complete
different story
but when as soon as my mother died
zoraida was my mother's best friend
and what people don't understand like
this is why i take friendship
very [__] seriously like mercy's
gonna be eight on friday
and i gotta tell you something i told my
wife this you know i go
i'm lucky i have mercy i'm lucky
that i have mercy because this year
particularly
i think somebody really got hurt i think
since
last december fate was for the last
year year and a half there's been a
handful of people
that indirectly and directly have been
[__] with me it doesn't bother me you
know me i give them all the rope in the
world
because i give them rope so they can
hang themselves i give them rope because
they don't know that i'm a [__]
savage
and i told my wife about a week ago we
were sitting upstairs can i believe can
you believe mercy's going to be [__]
eight
in a week and i said to her you know
what a lot of people should thank mercy
a lot of people should get up every
morning and go thank god for [__]
mercy
because if i didn't have mercy right now
the last couple years and i didn't have
and i i just had my wife let me tell you
something
in my 50s especially after what i've
accomplished already
i wouldn't mind doing a couple years in
jail you know what i'm saying just at
the end
just to prove my [__] point you know
like i wouldn't mind
i wouldn't mind dying in a [__] cell
and i know you people are crazy
you know i don't want to die in a cell
what i'm trying to say to you people is
if i didn't have mercy
the last eight years i mean i look at
mercy i kiss her every day like 25
[__] times
i kiss her in the morning i tell her i
love her but i thank her
i thank her every day my daughter knows
me
my daughter knows me better than most
[__] people
a lot of people you know this year was a
bad year
for my friends a lot of my friends got
beat up this year
and a lot of people that beat up my
friends if this if i didn't have mercy
i would have been shooting people i
don't know if you people know this about
me that i'm not all [__] there
and i don't like people messing with my
[__] friends i do not like it at all
a lot of my friends got messed with this
year i got messed with this year
a lot of people i cared for got messages
messed with this year and it's so weird
like
all you [__] better be thankful
i got mercy
because at 58 i'm crazier than [__]
that but trust me i get thoughts that
come into my mind
that would rattle you i am still a
[__] derelict criminal i just
the comedy and the family and everything
is taking all that stuff away from me
but trust me i have thoughts in my mind
like i forgave my wife my ex-wife i
don't
me and my wife are even me and mike's
wife are even i've forgiven everybody
everybody i'm not mad at anybody
i'm just letting you know i'm happy that
i have a daughter because i was like
i already did everything i wanted to do
i did movies
i did the comedy store the documentary
i'll be on the documentary like they'll
go that guy was on the documentary he's
doing time for stabbing a [__]
ten times
or shooting somebody i swear to [__]
god
i have i'm thankful for mercy you know
and when i was younger i was out of my
[__] mind
and but zeraida could always calm me
down
so after my mother died you know i mean
my mother died at three in the morning
and zoraida was already there
i think i called her at [__] eight
and zerita got there i don't know maybe
9 30.
she lived in long island at the time and
she used to
her operation was out of spanish harlem
113th
by the by spanish island by the park
that was her operation there
she had a second floor apartment over a
little [__] bodega
i'm not dog i could live to be 80 i'll
never forget
being a kid and walking up those steps
in the 70s and seeing all the junkies
[__] nodding in the hallways and it
was way better than going to any [__]
zoo
or any movie or any [__] love bug in
the world like i
i knew they were on some type of drug i
just didn't know what
and but i enjoyed seeing people like all
[__] i mean that
that's that's why i think i dose people
from me seeing all those people at a
young age
all [__] she lived on the second floor
so we had to go
this way and then there was like a
landing and then you went up to the
second floor and you knocked
the door it was like two doors in the
hallway
let me tell you something there would
always be three dudes like three monkeys
you like those three [__] monkeys
there would be three of them
laid out [__] vomit next to them it
was
disgusting but so entertaining when
you're six and seven
that you f i love going up there i would
beg my mother take me this all right
it's not you gotta go to school today
[__]
i'm not gonna be able to see the [__]
whatever the whole
neighborhood was great they had great
food downstairs it was spanish harlem
it was the [__] 70s they had this
thing called the mangetta i don't know
if it's still there
oh my god lord they had good [__] in
there
so every time i would love going over to
sarah this one when my mother died
you know she was my mother's best friend
i called her up i told her
that we found my mother she showed up
she pretty much you know i was out of it
throughout the whole week
she pretty much carried the wake you
know she did the whole [__] thing
she waited there until they buried my
mother and then she goes
i'm gonna stay with you for two weeks i
want you to stay here for two weeks and
settle in
let me stay with you let me take care of
you cook for you
and thanksgiving you can move in with
the benders
my mother died on the eighth i think
they buried it like on the 12th or the
13th or something like that
so she stayed with me for those 10 days
and we really got to talk
we got to talk about my mother she told
me about where she came from in cuba
when she stabbed the [__] guy with
from her sister
you know she told me a lot of things
about my mother i didn't know it was
really
it was really great of her you know and
then
thanksgiving day i moved in with the
benders and
every sunday i would meet the rider at a
bar called
otto's in union city it was on 30th and
new york avenue there
i forget the guy that owned it he was he
played for the chicago bulls from union
city he's dead
rest in peace thank god he's dead they
used to rob him like every other week
the poor bastard i used to work in that
i used to work in that bar that guy gave
me a bartending job
at 17 years old i quit high school
and i had the wednesday at 7 a.m
shift and monday nights
but that came later don't worry about
that that came later
when i was you know my mom died when i
was fifteen sixteen
sorry to stay with me and then
she made a [__] promise that she was
going to take care of me
until i got to be a man and i got to
tell you guys
i learned a lot from her i learned
that experience of being around her
got me here with you guys because it
taught me
how to be a friend it taught me
what friends do and it taught me that
it's not about money like everybody
thinks it's about money
and boats and [__] and get your dick
sucked and hanging out with celebrities
let me tell you what it's about
it's about friendships man your
bank account doesn't match
the value of your friendships if if
you if you have two 20 million dollars
but you don't have good friends your
life ain't worth [__]
and you just don't get good friends you
have to
grow good friends you have to water
friends
and they water you it's the same [__]
thing it's cultivating
you just not you people think that
you're just going to go online
swipe and meet the woman of your [__]
dreams and it's going to all work out
then they get mad at you and you when
they get well i've been married four
times because you made four bad [__]
choices
you didn't cultivate your [__]
friendships i've cultivated my
friendships
and i learned from zoraida because i saw
how her and my mother did it
from the time i was [__] four to the
just 16 till she died i saw two people
who had each other's back [__]
without
any reservation do you understand me i
mean that's the first story she told me
was how my mother went down with my
father and
saved her in chicago because zoraida had
come
to this country her my mother would
tighten
cuba my mother went to new york with my
father
jersey and zara new york jersey and
zarida
went with her new construction
cop husband i think it was a cop in cuba
to chicago and then when they got to
chicago he started beating her severely
and started pimping her out she called
my mother
my mother and manolo my father got a gun
and a [__] knife and a broom
and like a [__] dustpan yeah my
mother
she told me they came with a broom and a
knife and [__] you know
and they pulled her out of there in
chicago and they drove it back to
[__] new york
they helped to set up a business until
this and that's how she became
[__] wealthy my father lent us some
money so she always felt connected
like she owed my mother so through that
connection after my father died
she came she could have just left me
alone guys and not giving a [__]
no she stayed with me for those two
weeks and then she made a promise to me
that every sunday
she would come and guys
from the time my mother died to the time
i left
april 25th 1983 to colorado
she showed up every sunday or at least
every other sunday
we meet at otto's we drive
down to [__] the cemetery i just
thought of her driver's face that's so
weird
we'd uh should bring a bottle of pinch
for my mother and spread it on the
[__] grave
put some bumps on my mother's grave
throw me 200 cash
and give me a nickel bag from spanish
hall
i would call her every day i would talk
to her every day she wanted me to
check it you know she always wanted me
to check in check in she told me
i want you to take the place of your
mother
do you remember how mean your mother
spoke three times a day
yes that's what good friends do call me
in the morning call me at lunch and call
me a dinner
so every day i was trained she trained
me
she goes this is what friends do you
check in she goes me and your mother
have been doing this since
1940 checking in and checking in
and she sometimes i would call like
after six months that my mother died i
would call
her she would cry she goes i could still
hear that same
tone that your mother has in your voice
even though you're a man it's weird
because
i hear it in my uncle when i speak to my
uncle
i kind of get emotional for like a
minute because i hear my mother and his
voice also so i
i understand what zoraida was saying to
me
the writer took care of me guys from
with never complaining never threw it in
my face
never said nothing to me you know
yes i did lie to her to get money from
her from time to time
even though she was going to give it to
me anyway i just wanted to expedite it
or something you know
i loved her it wasn't like i was using
her i loved her with all my heart
she had become like my second mom you
know
uh that wasn't the case at all
it just was uh i was young
i was dumb and i was [__] stupid
you know i was every time i go into the
city to do something illegal
i'd always stop by her and check in with
her
i'd go downstairs with my own money
and i'd buy her a cuban sandwich and to
surprise her and bring her upstairs to
her
i knew she liked cuba sandwiches from a
certain spot
so uh you know i tried my best
when i went to colorado i kept in touch
with her i did exactly what she said i
called her
every [__] day when i was in colorado
she did not send me money
i did not let her send me money i told
her i was fine
even though she would call me and say do
you need me to send you money
nah i thought by 83 by the time
i was [__] 20 i was too old for
somebody to give me money i mean you
know
i at that time listen i didn't even take
social security when your parents die
you're supposed to collect social
security for some reason or another they
said my mother didn't work enough
quarters and my father
but i could have [__] fought it and
took it to court or whatever got an
attorney
i said i'm not taking money from the
country i'm just i'd rather steal it
from a drug dealer
than take money out of the [__] you
know disability claims or some fake
[__]
thing like that and that's what i did i
didn't take any money from colorado
it was all my own money then when i came
back
in 84 85 84 february of 84
i would take coke from her i wouldn't
take money i'd go no no i don't need any
money
i'll take the coke and sell it at that
time she she had horrible cocaine it was
horrible
it was street cocaine harlem cocaine you
know
50 pure [__] like that i would sell it
to some
idiots i knew and make some extra cash
and they would cut it or smoke it or
shoot it i had no idea
but i love zory i always bought a
christmas presents
i did everything in my world but then 84
came
and uh
84 was this is why i tell peop you know
i didn't journal
in 79 i didn't journal in 1980
i didn't journal in 82 i didn't journal
i didn't journal in 84 and this is why i
believe in the journal because in 1984
i pretty much had a nervous breakdown
from what happened to me in 1979
you know when you like right now
i'm a different person i know this you
know
my stand-up is different my podcast is
different
why what is the answer is joe diaz not
funny anymore
no i'm still a funny [__] i
still feel it i really do still feel it
what is going on is that i'm mourning a
loss i'm wanting a life loss
a whole life got taken from me you know
the comedy store
the road it all got taken from me so
there has to be
some type of feeling if i didn't get up
and write about this every [__] day
how i feel
and why i'm feeling this way and why i
have little bouts of anxiety
if i didn't do this every day now in
about two or three years from now i'd
have the nervous breakdown
i had an 84. this is why i [__]
journal
and this is why i preach that [__]
as much as i do somebody on patreon the
other day
hit me up and they said hey man we don't
want to blow smoke up your ass i started
journaling three months ago
my life has changed completely
listen you got to check on those
skeletons from time to time they don't
they don't like to sit in the closet
alone you got to check in on those
[__] from time to time
and with journaling you do it and we all
have skeletons in the closet
we all have our own personal skeletons
in our [__] head
you know i have
what i did with zarida the only way i
forgave myself
when 84 came i lost my [__] mind you
know
i lost my mind over the drugs i lost my
mind
over the [__] uh you always have
these people they call you twice you
have anybody who calls you [__] twice
why you calling me twice
if i didn't pick up the first time what
makes you think i'm gonna pick up the
[__] second time
what the [__] is wrong with people you
know i was like nah now welcome to my
[__] world cup
suckers so uh
84 was just one of those years that
the five years of me partying with my
buddies
sweeping the pain of my mother's death
under the carpet
catches up with you that's why i tell
people to journal and that's why i tell
people if you go through something
traumatic especially next week like once
i get the surgery done
i will write about it because i know
that those [__] vicodins those
[__]
whatever they give me are gonna [__] up
my head so i have to stay grounded
the only way to stay grounded is by
writing
your situation and explaining to
yourself what is going on in your
[__] head
i watch what's going on in my head
constantly
i keep an eye on it constantly because i
saw
i ended up homeless and 84 from it
so ever since that time i [__]
journal and i
keep ground like this time here i have
kept pretty much grounded look at my
face look at my eyes look at my eyeballs
i'm grounded i am fine if i wouldn't
have done
the work i did to stay grounded i would
have been [__] up there would have
been no podcast
half the time this is like a [__]
hump fest anyway
but sometimes i come up and i deliver so
the more i keep doing this by law i
shouldn't even be allowed to do a
podcast right now
because i'm wanting a [__] life i'm
mourning a life that i lost
you know i'm mourning the loss of valley
village i'm i'm warning driving down
colfax
i'm mourning seeing lee leah morning you
know
seeing my friends seeing rogan i'm
warning going to my church
which was the comedy store i'm mourning
all that in the back of my mind
i'm not supposed to know that but i know
it because i already went through this
30 [__] years ago do you understand
me
so if you feel you're going through
something and you don't know what it is
you're mourning your old life maybe you
were a [__] i don't know
maybe you were a [__] i don't know maybe
you were yeah maybe you were
a a singer in a band and you were just
about to take off and this [__] thing
happened
you know we all have these [__]
stories back to the writer anyway
uh you know i got hired the drugs and
[__] and what really happened with
zaratha was this
zoraida was taking care of me okay not
she wasn't giving me kilos
i don't use a coke i would go to her
house and get like a grant from her
two grams 3 grams no big [__] deal
i started trying to be a [__] dealer
you know here she is
telling me listen man don't [__] with
that stuff you know
if i'm giving you this and you're
selling it to one of your friends
that's one thing but if you're out there
selling it on the street you're gonna
end up [__]
in jail and then i can't help you and
i'm like no i'm just selling it to my
friends and that was the truth i was
just giving it like a friend of mine
it wasn't the coke that i would usually
that i liked my friends didn't want that
strong so this is what i gave to them
i uh she didn't want me to sell coke
but you know i'm watching i
you know i'm watching all my friends
being big shots and i'm [__] poor
and i'm [__] broke and i'm [__]
making a [__] shitty waves like
everybody else
i mean what would you have done so i
started trying to sell coke i couldn't i
was a horrible coke salesman
i would do good for a week and then i
would snort everything and then people
would be looking for me for two weeks
and i have to disappear for two weeks
and then i come back it was
[__] hell so i went to miami and i
[__] uh
a friend of my mother's thought that
i was top-notch friends with like the
mafia they they had
carmine balzano confused so this guy
kept [__]
caught looking for me people kept
telling me on the streets muneco's
looking for you this guy in
miami not to hurt me but he wanted to
talk to me because some chick
had given his son a hot shot up an angle
with clips or something
and he wanted the people that gave his
son the hot shot
he wanted them killed and he was looking
for somebody to kill him
so he wanted to talk to me about talking
to one of my mafia buddies
about killing these people this was my
life at 1984
when i was 21. so if you think you got
problems
listen to that [__] story so here i
am talking to this guy
and i'm like yeah yeah yeah yeah i'll
get the mafia to [__]
kill the [__] people but you got to
give me a good price on a [__] kilo
he's like no worries i'll give you
[__] wholesale prices
so i was working with him and i was
doing okay but
you know how the [__] story goes if
you're throwing up spaghetti against the
wall it's gonna [__] stick
i went up to north bergen and one
weekend i ended up doing all the [__]
coke
and i ended up spending the [__]
money and i didn't have the [__]
twenty thousand so i never called him
back so i thought
that he was gonna call as a writer and
complain to the writer
because they were tight they all knew
each other so i was scared if i called
the writer
she was going to give me a [__]
tremendous ear beating
make me go down there and pay him and
say all this [__]
so what did i do i took the ezreal cause
i was a [__] loser
i just stopped calling zoraida like in
september of 84.
right after i burned muneco i waited
about a week
and i was like i can't call as a writer
and then
i was going to places and people were
telling me some ladies he called
here like she knew my friend's numbers
and she started calling their houses
looking for me and i was like
she definitely [__] knows now i'm
[__] dead
and then i ended up going to california
i ended up going here i was ducking
people
i ended up going back to north very good
and i ended up homeless
and then in fact i spoke to mr t
this morning happy new year mr t mr t
was my high school teacher
and january 1st 1985 mr t took me in
with the plan of taking me to a detox
and then for me to rehab that's a
complete different story
but after t picked me up
and i got to sleep for two weeks and
relax
and get my head together and get the
cocaine out of my system
i was like [__] the writer
what have i [__] done you know
i picked up the phone i remember i was i
was out in the street somewhere and it
was like a [__] pay phone you know
[Music]
i picked up the payphone i called her
she's like where the [__] have you been
do you know what happened to me she goes
i've been calling
for months looking for you where have
you been like and i go
you know what happened and she goes i
don't know what happened she goes
you know you know what happened the cops
raided me and
and during the raid one of the cops
[__] fell on me and he broke my
[__] leg in two places
and they took everything i had and they
[__] seized my bank accounts
and she goes on that they put a lien on
my [__] house and all this and
and where the [__] were you when all
this happened you didn't call one
[__] time
to check up on me and guys i gotta tell
you something
it broke my heart because she was
absolutely right she had been there for
me
for everything and what because of
cocaine
i didn't call her back and she didn't
even know the guy monieco never even
[__] called her
she didn't mention it at all in the
conversation because i said i go
called you she goes i haven't heard from
municho since [__] august or july
what the [__] are you talking about
so i was like i didn't talk to you
because i didn't tell her that
because i thought muneco and [__] and
she's like you know
this is not good i i was there for you
when your mother died she was right
i just started bawling and i remember
just letting the phone drop
out of my [__] hand and i walked away
from the [__] pay phone because she
was right
she had every [__] right and let me
tell you something guys it took me
a year to [__] forgive myself took me
a year i felt like [__]
for a [__] year but i made the
decision
that if i ever had a friend again that
changed
everything for me that changed
everything from me
that's a riot a phone call is the reason
that i still talk to danny b jimmy
lebrano you know timmy holloway
georgie k you know jimmy v
my man anthony venery the reason why i
talk to all those guys
after 45 [__] years
because we're talking i know these guys
are 75
73 the reason why i talked to these guys
and all the people who covered my ass
when my mom died
was because i didn't want them to feel
like the writer did on that day
you know i could be the biggest [__]
scumbag in the world
but i could also be your best [__]
friend
when i'm your [__] friend man i'm
your friend to the [__] end
i will [__] drive there with you i
don't care about the felony i don't care
about the gun
i'm not a hollywood guy somebody [__]
with you i'm your friend
it's lights out dog
i remember when [__] those people
going after me on twitter
for making rogan laugh about the [__]
chick who [__] blew me
uh there's a comic that he [__]
raised his hand
a couple male comics raise their hands
huh
did you see it by one of them one of
them
well one of them raised their hand he's
like he's not all
he not only got his dick sucked he threw
a bottle at me one night at the comedy
store i didn't see that i oh yeah i
threw a bottle at this [__] him
and another comic thought they were
being cute with me
they would say to me that i was only
funny because i did cocaine before i
went on stage
i swear to god i never did cocaine
before i went on stage so i whipped the
[__] bottle at that [__] one
night him
and another comic they ran away one
night i [__]
then another guy that hit me up last
week i drew a [__]
uh uh i told him not to touch the
microphone so he [__]
because the thing was off and he touched
the mic and the wire broke
and we ended up going to war and i had
to throw a bunch of [__]
pool pool ball put balls on and [__]
then there was another comic oh another
comic said that one night
not only did he get his dick sucked he
also tried to run me over with his car
one night and holy [__]
which i did i told him to get out of the
way didn't want to get out of the way so
i [__] hit him with the [__] car
he didn't sue
[__] him you know anyway it happened
but because of the riders
because of what happened with zoraida
when i was 20
i never wanted that to happen
again with me and anybody else listen
you try i was thinking about
i went to the gym today okay i loved it
i love my gym i love the gym when i go
to
i pay them they train me i love it
but i realized something today i'm gonna
walk out that after we train
and after i go to the locker and get my
water and my car keys on the walker
when i say see you later take just my
acquaintances
they're nice guys they're nice kids i
love them to death
i paid them you know i love them to
death but then my acquaintances
and then we move up a ring and we have
i have my friends you know
and mike is becoming a great friend i
mean i've been friends with mike for a
while
now i'm starting to care about mike now
if you [__] with mike i gotta stab you
in the [__] neck
you know we were acquaintances but now
he's my brother and now i gotta stab you
in the neck
anybody who's my [__] friend anybody
like rogan
arie you know they all know
that things go down with them i'm there
i'm the first one there i don't care
about
you know but now i have to care because
of my daughter
i can't go to jail because of somebody
else because of my daughter i can't have
my daughter
see me in a prison [__] uniform but
if you
[__] with one of my friends enough you
know what happens
what happened i mean what you know i'd
have to tell my daughter that this is
what
being a friend is somebody [__] up one
of my friends and i had to go over they
hit him in the head with a pipe
you know they decided to rap me out
because they're [__] [__]
instead of [__] being a man and hit
me back with the [__] pipe whatever
i'm just saying that you know
this is the year right now 19 19
2021 you know this is your year
you i love this time of the year and i
love
mondays you know why i love mondays
because we're all
equal this today
january 6th makes us all
equal think about that we just paid
rent we're all equal
i haven't made any money you make any
money and many money
i haven't been on the road i haven't
done anything you do it it makes us
all equal that's what i love about the
beginning of the year
that whatever happened the year before
you could [__] erase it it's done
that's why i don't understand how you're
gonna come back at that supreme court
justice
and say he covered your mouth at a party
and they go [__] yourself you dumb [__]
next time don't fall asleep at the party
he's lucky he covered your mouth
if that was my party and one of my
parties in jersey those guys would have
[__] in the ass and left you there
and put your pants back on you wouldn't
know nothing till you're taking a [__]
and a little blood come out of your ass
you're lucky he covered your mouth
that's why i don't like none of that
[__]
something that happened 20 years ago
that was a different person you know
what the other day my wife made
something for me to eat
and i was like you know what give this a
break and i go not because it's bad
but because i don't like it anymore my
tastes have changed
it's like i've said a thousand times
people [__] change
people [__] change so you know you
can't judge them
on what they did 23 [__] years ago 23
years ago yeah i got a blood job from a
chick
that would come there once a week can i
get on stage yeah whatever
you know you got to do whatever the [__]
you got to do you know
wait she was the first one what do you
think that
this i knew we were friends it was like
a [__] joke
no big deal you're the [__]
that you know
gentile central oh my god but the guys
that went off
you know they went off
my point is that it's a new year you got
a new start
and if you want to work on something
this year because i see a lot of
this and emails from younger guys is
that they're lonely they don't know how
to make friends with this [__]
pandemic a lot of people are in bad
positions listen
it all starts with one friend and all
you need is
three and you could take over the
[__] world
how do i know because i've done it have
i taken over the world
no i'm not [__] gengar genghis khan
what i mean taking over my world is i've
taken over my world
what i do for a living i've excelled at
because of those three friends if you
don't have
one or two friends that lift you
you need to work on that
nobody's gonna come and lift you you
have to try
to lift them i mike
has been lifting me for years
that's why now we lift each other and
our relationship has grown
so if you're lonely this year learn how
to work on your friendships
you don't need 10 people everybody
always wants to have a party with 12
people oh my god
i'm so loved and wait till the belt wait
till the time comes
let's see how much they love you
everybody's looking around scratching
who's gonna pick up that [__] pad
go [__] yourself three people is all i
need
three people we could take over the
[__] world not the world
it's like i'm gonna go to china and go
this is my [__] world no
what i can control my world
three people today is a writer's
birthday
i wanted to wish her a happy birthday
and do this podcast and her name to her
uh and for her to find a way in her
heart
to forgive me for what i did uh
after i did that i swore that i would be
a better friend to my friends and i am
you know when i'm your friend now
i'm your friend learn to be a friend
don't worry about being popular don't
worry about having
eight people or a crew you're never
gonna have a crew
because one of the eight's gonna flip on
you you dumb [__]
the more people you add to your crew the
more chances you got
of people flipping on you all you need
is one or two
you don't want to do a crime with three
because then two can flip on one
that's a completely different thing i'm
talking about friendship here okay
as far as friendship is concerned that's
what this podcast is about today
you know she showed me the gift of
friendship and i want to share it with
you
you want good friends you're not just
going to get them
because you know you have those friends
that try to buy you
you know let's go to france i'll pay no
no
it's not about that it's about having
each other's back
having each other's balance friendship
is a balance
you know while i've been here in jersey
i've learned one thing
that i have a great wife we work well
together
i don't like raking leaves she likes
making leaves you know what i
she don't like take out the garbage i
like taking out the garbage
me and my wife are a team together that
just didn't happen
that just doesn't happen you have to
work on it
you have to eat some [__] from time to
time
you have to eat some [__] and say you're
sorry
or say i feel this way you know
i've never lasted with a woman like this
but when i
hooked up with my wife before i that's
why it took me nine years to marry her
i said if she's gonna be my wife i'm
gonna be a husband i don't wanna do what
i did
last time and fail i don't like failing
at things two times guys
i don't like it i don't mind failing at
something one time
a particular thing i failed at a lot of
things
i felt everything if you [__] really
look at it
but i don't like failing doing one thing
twice
there's no call for that first time
shame on me
second time show first time shame on you
second time shame on me i don't like
failing or something like that so
that's the episode for today i'm
dedicating this to sarita
uh it's her birthday today up in heaven
i wish i had a picture of her i'd light
a candle for her but i don't
she was beautiful she was she was cuban
black black african cuban
and she had blonde hair way before
little came this is 79
this [__] already had a tight little
blonde head dude she looked like dennis
rodman before the operation
but she was good looking zorrita and you
know what man
40 [__] years later i still really
miss her i miss her conversations
and i miss what she did for me if you
take anything from this podcast i
remember
friends just don't [__] pop up out of
the [__] ground
you got to cultivate them you got to
work on it you got to let them know
you're in and they need to know
that you'll [__] die for them you
know like i said to you those names i
mentioned earlier
timmy george jimmy lubes
these guys me and this is what that's
who got me to the place
my friends who got me to this place
your friends should be lifting you up
not tearing you
down that's what friends do i hope you
enjoyed this podcast today
uh thank you for the patreon thank you
for always
giving me love on twitter and uh
and facebook i guess periscope
ain't out of business yet right another
business yeah
i don't know let me check and see you
because they were supposed to be out of
business
but then the other day so let me do a
[__] periscope
oh [__] periscope is not out of business
they changed their mind they said [__]
it we're gonna keep doing what we're
doing
anyway that's what i want to talk to you
about friendship today
it's 2020 21 it's a new year
you have a new start um
you know i talk to rogan every week i
talk to timmy every week
i talked to dean delray every week i
talked to lee every [__] day
i took daddy bravo i talked to sam
tripley
i talked to jimmy florentine mike and i
talked he you know we [__] talk at
night
you know i call him he's putting the
baby to sleep
you gotta the friends just don't you
know i even checked him
for you people if you want to hate me i
even checked him with dalia
and i yelled at dalia yesterday i wished
him a happy [__] new year or two days
ago
i wished him a happy new year and i said
what are you [__] waiting for
what are you waiting for that's it
nobody else came out
nobody said that you had sex with them
when they were 17.
nobody else said nothing you text
somebody they were under age
it was a [__] mistake that's it what
you you're done forever
i said when is the podcast gonna start
and when you're gonna put yourself back
out there again
you know people are not people
just don't forgive you you have to ask
for forgiveness
so i gave him advice i hope he takes it
and uh
that's it man if you're in a bind
ask for forgiveness if they're your
friends they'll see it if they're not
your friends
[__] them who the [__] are they to judge
you right or wrong it's like lying
like willie nelson never lie to your
friends if you lie to him you're gonna
[__] if they're your friends you're
gonna ruin
it with a lie and if they're not your
friends who the [__] are they
that you gotta lie to him [__] him i
love you guys thank you very much
for watching the joint i hope to be back
on monday
with everything i got i hope to be back
uh if you know anything about me i will
be here monday
half [__] bike i didn't die with my
leg out we'll figure it out
but thank you for all the support thank
you for all the well wishes
and thank you for just listening to the
podcast and the patreon and everything
else we have to offer
stay black and now for a word
from our sponsors all right [__]
thank you
for this little tate tate thank you
for all the well wishes on the surgery
on friday
hopefully we'll be able to do a podcast
next monday
let's see how i feel i don't know if my
legs gonna be sticking right
up i don't know if i'm gonna be too
[__] up on the [__]
pills they give you i don't [__] know
what's gonna happen all i know is
i'm here today i'm having the surgery
friday i appreciate you [__]
with everything that i got for always
having my back all right but before i go
from the heart of jersey the joint is
brought to you by
draft [__] kings you understand
me
listen if you haven't signed up yet now
is the time
download the draftking sportsbook app
today you're like joey why because it's
safe
secure and reliable and it's your money
deposit and withdraw
at your [__] convenience this
weekend
is the [__] playoffs get ready
there's no better place to get in on the
action
than draftkings why joey what because
they're america's top rated sportsbook
you [__]
if you haven't tried them yet what the
[__] are you waiting for
to celebrate the best time of the year
right now january
right now this is ghee this month if
you're not [__] around you
what are you doing draftkings is giving
you a shot at doubling your [__]
money did you hear what i have to say
you're gonna double your money this
[__] saturday all it takes
is one touchdown for you to double your
money like i told you in the beginning
i'm gonna paint a picture for you all
right you're gonna wake up saturday go
to breakfast
get two pieces of bacon maybe a piece of
toast three eggs sunny side up
you gotta smoke a number maybe give mama
a stabbing
and then you're gonna open up draftkings
place your bet
and as soon as the [__] first
touchdown hits you're getting paid
you could take a nappy new new time
who's better than you who's better than
you
nobody don't sleep on basketball either
tonight
because it's going down there's daily
odds boost on the app
every [__] day like i told you if you
haven't signed up yet
you're [__] slipping because this
week is [__] on
you got tonight you got college
basketball thursday night
college pro basketball friday night and
[__] saturday and sunday
nfl playoffs and draftkings is kicking
it off
with one touchdown and you double your
money are you [__] crazy
download the top rated draftking
sportsbook app right now
and use promo code joey when you sign up
to have a shot
at doubling your [__] money if your
touchdown is scored
this saturday not sunday this saturday
that's co joey for new players to get a
shot at doubling their money
this saturday for a limited time
only only a draftking sports book and
here's the part the lawyers make me say
you got to be 21 or older new jersey
indiana pennsylvania
there's some other states have been
added tennessee colorado
see draftkings.com sportsbook for
details now
if you got a gambling problem there's
help
call 1-800 gambler or if you're in
indiana call 1-809
with it but if you ain't got no [__]
problems
let's go download this [__] app and
let's make some money use
code joey and cash in on this
[__] deal today
saturday [__] let's make some cash
the joint is also brought to you by
onyx listen you know how i feel about
them
nine nine ten years i've been working
with them
i've been taking this product for maybe
12 years joe rogan used to turn me on to
alpha brain i'll tell you what man i
don't do them every day i go on six week
cycles but alpha brain is the [__]
[__]
especially now when people are going
through what they're going through
you know i'm not saying it's a [__]
cure all i'm saying in the flu
it improves your memory and it helps you
with your focus like it did for me
they got an instant they got a pill for
them
we got shrew tech sports room tech
immune
i mean listen it doesn't end i could sit
here for two hours
and talk to you about the benefits on it
look for yourself go to honor.com right
now
look at the supplements look at the
protein bites
look at the equipment they have i can't
do nothing for you on equipment but on
the supplements and the protein bites i
get you 10
off delivered right to your house press
church
on the way out and get 10 delivered
right to your [__] crib
that's it and that's that i want to
thank honey
and i want to thank draftkings for
having my back
and i want to thank you guys and uh
thank you for all the well wishes
we'll see what happens friday but i'll
keep you posted
via patreon and via twitter and all that
[__] i love you [__]
candles always lit here have a great
[__] weekend stay black
you